[Music]
what's up guys michael here now you
don't have to be much of a crypto
enthusiast to know that something weird
is going on with digital art and that
something is called nfts see auction
house christie's just sold its first
purely digital artwork and the
accompanying non-fungible token for a
chill 69 million dollars both art
insiders and normies were left
collectively stunned the work in
question is every days the first 5 000
days by digital artist beeple it's a
composite image of the artist's daily
digital pictures made over the course of
13 and a half years this wasn't the only
big ticket nft sale either grimes has
sold millions of dollars in blockchain
art while an nft of the nian cat sold
for more than half a million dollars
worth of crypto and so since basically
everyone at wisecrack was pretty baffled
we started digging we had so many
questions mostly
why is this just a gimmick are these
millionaire nfc consumers just way
smarter than us do they just really want
to give artists their due with fair
compensation
and what we found ended up raising a ton
of questions about the art world like
why do we take for granted the fact that
a painting like this receives bids for
millions of dollars while a painting of
me showing whole as as of now received
zero bids it made us wonder what if we
treat people's 69 million dollar payday
as less of a novelty and more of a
natural progression of the art world one
that's been underway for the last
five-ish decades let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on non-fungible tokens
before we jump in a quick word on nfts
nfts are basically unique units of data
on a blockchain that are used to
represent a digital item they act as
proof of ownership of that digital item
and some people think they're a pretty
big scam that's because when you buy an
nft you're more or less purchasing a
super special file with a digital seal
of authenticity that says even if this
file is widely available on the internet
it's actually you who own it oh and
they're also real bad for the
environment but that's a topic for
another day to understand the wild money
being thrown at the peoples and grimes's
of the world we need to talk about an
art movement that emerged in full force
around 2011 and was soon given the
scornful nickname zombie formalism let's
unpack the story by starting with what's
formalism and what's a zombie version of
it here's the deal formless art critics
who really came to prominence after
world war ii believed in judging artwork
based entirely on the success of the
aesthetics colors lines shapes rather
than any social political or ideological
context so sorry picasso we don't care
if guernica is about the spanish civil
war we care that it looks dope some
formalists like critic clement greenberg
also believe that art that represented
actual things or people was inherently
inferior to the more pure abstract
expressionism exemplified by the likes
of notable paint dripper jackson pollock
these abstract works it was thought
reached for a higher kind of truth that
said greenberg's views started really
falling out of favor in the late 70s as
high art people became increasingly
preoccupied with contextualizing artwork
and all the ways greenberg hated so for
instance you'd have someone like
jean-michel basquiat being discussed and
celebrated for the ways they used
symbolism and commented on the art world
at large fast forward a few decades and
we can get to the zombie part of zombie
formalism these mostly young artists
reviving a decades-old way of thinking
about and making art but as a shell of
its former self in the vein of their
predecessors they were focused on
technique color and composition more
than symbolism or context it was also
characterized by what art critic jerry
saltz describes as the illusion of true
originality the movement was fueled by
first like the first painting made via
electroplating or the first painting
made via fire extinguisher which okay
sounds pretty cool salts notes that the
art felt new and dangerous but not too
much so it also seemed cerebral and was
tailor-made to look good in wealthy
people's fancy contemporary homes and on
instagram the paintings all looked
pretty similar in their simple elegance
exemplified by lucy and smith's reign
series they could also generally be made
very efficiently and sold like hundred
thousand dollar hotcakes newbie art
collectors many of whom hailed from the
finance world loved them and were
excited to speculate wildly on artists
whose street cred seem to be majorly on
the rise though they're aesthetically
super different it's hard not to see
some surface similarities between the
current nft bonanza and this art moment
at its peak let's take a close look at
the imagery that actually constitutes
beeples every day is the first 5 000
days art keep in mind each of these
individual tiles is now technically
worth nearly 14 000
as one artnet journalist notes the
images include a lot of corny cartoons
and ironic political characters that
seem to be aiming for edgy but end up
more in the camp of memes your boomer
dad might forward after two for one
margarita hour at chili's it has tones
of subversiveness if watching lincoln
spank trump strikes you as particularly
subversive yet doesn't appear to possess
a clear ideology many of the works could
best be described as different kinds of
racist or sexist posting it also pulls
pretty shamelessly from me internet
aesthetics seen on tumblr and deviantart
and look i'm not a monster i love weird
internet art and i love memes but when
exactly is a meme worth 14 grand
people's work was tailor made for
internet consumption and in many cases
clearly dashed off pretty quickly in
fact people told insider that he never
expected to sell a piece of his digital
art for more than one thousand dollars
like many works of zombie formalism
every days is ultimately most remarkable
for two completely non-artistic reasons
a it's novelty
here as the first purely digital art
piece to make it through the gold
standard of industry art auctions and b
its resulting price tag
the same could be said of nian cat which
is like old internet novelty wrapped in
new internet novel ta a novelty
quesarito if you will now it may not
seem unusual these days to judge art
primarily by its market value but just a
few generations ago such a perspective
would have been virtually unthinkable
that's because the idea of defining and
measuring the true value of art by its
price i.e as a commodity is relatively
new as curator henry geldzahler noted
abstract painters who hone their craft
in the 40s and 50s were more focused on
projecting the imminence of god in their
work than eking out a high price point
though many artists were still aware of
the patron class they were appealing to
and the monetary worth of their work
this kind of calculating was considered
distasteful and thus kept private art
collectors in turn were focused on say
building an aesthetically pleasing
collection of work you could show off to
friends dinner parties or show off to
the world by loaning it out to a museum
it wasn't primarily about the monetary
value of the art itself this began to
change somewhat drastically in the early
70s with the meteoric rise in the value
of pop art a movement that had been
since the 1950s preoccupied with the
notion of branding and commodities
exemplified by andy warhol these artists
owned international brands and their
work increasingly began attracting more
investment-minded collectors of course
as sculptor richard sarah notes artists
like warhol simultaneously branded
themselves while mocking the media that
perpetuated those brands that is there
was a subversiveness to this ethos of
commodification of art however the
criticality and subversiveness that
warhol embodied has been according to
sarah lost and that loss began in
earnest in the 80s as art along with
just about everything else became fully
commodified as art historian tiernan
morgan argues the art world as we
recognize it today was largely
manufactured by the decade's commercial
prowess and were still grappling with
its fallout this sea change was in part
due to the economic surge of money
belonging to the top one percent it was
also due to increased marketing efforts
by auction houses and the meteoric rise
of galleries and art fairs by the
mid-80s front page stories about
despicably expensive auction sales
constituted much of the media's coverage
of the art world this mindset that art
equals money would only become more
entrenched at the turn of the new
century at this point according to art
expert michael finley serious critical
discourse was drowned out by the noise
of the marketplace at the same time the
typical artist has become increasingly
preoccupied with creating maintaining
and increasing his or her market whereas
many artists in the 60s like edward
keenholes roundly mocked the very idea
of commodifying art in general many
artists have now become comfortable
seeing their work primarily as
commodities to be bought and sold indeed
one of the fallen stars of zombie
formalism lucien smith admitted recently
that his time in the spotlight was about
sucking up the collectors and trying to
sell for the highest prices he now
laments that stuff isn't real that's not
art so we might ask is a grimes or
beeple nft really worth millions
but it's kind of the wrong question one
fueled by an art market cynically
concerned with price rather than merit
fittingly as art became more commodified
collecting art became increasingly less
about amassing a pretty collection of
monets and more about creating a pretty
investment portfolio nowadays much of
art is bought only to be stored in
high-end international warehouses far
away from the homes and walls of the
buyer all of which is to say these days
the price of an artwork is the point
this has perhaps never been more clear
than in another recent blockchain
purchase that of a banksy painting after
purchasing the nft for a work by your
favorite rat portraitist the new owners
proceeded to burn the original painting
in order to ensure the exclusive value
of their token the breathless media
coverage is probably just a happy side
effect right anyway here we see how the
price of the commodity i.e the nft
trumps all even the cultural worth of
the original tangible work of art so now
that we know how the art market became a
commercialized mini horror show it's
worth asking how does the market set a
price for a piece of artwork the answer
pretty randomly as art critic robert
hughes put it the price of a work of art
is an index of pure irrational desires
part of this has to do with the auction
setting which is literally designed to
foster reckless spontaneous decision
making notably while christie's will
typically set an estimated value they
chose not to on every days because of
the novelty of an nft as a result the
sky quite literally was the limit as
prices in an auction climb so does
excitement as finlay notes people are
lured by art that because it was
expensive presumably must be good often
this reason replaced meaningful scrutiny
of the object there's another factor
that makes certain big ticket pieces of
art worth more money than god as
christie's estimates there are
approximately 150 collectors in the
world with the means and desire to spend
more than 20 million dollars on a piece
of artwork and i'm sad to say not one of
them is my friend many of these
investors hardly art experts in and of
themselves rely on the help of seasoned
art advisors who tend to have relatively
homogeneous taste as a result as scholar
ola velthus explains the art market
functions as a big consensus marketing
machine that is to say it runs primarily
on hype art advisors keep track of which
artists brands are currently favored by
powerful curators collectors and museums
and as valthus concludes because
everybody is to some extent at least
looking at the same signals at one point
they start agreeing on who are the most
desirable artists as a result top
collectors tend to gravitate towards the
same artisan works or the same trends
thus driving prices super way up of
course that might explain the exorbitant
price tag on say a jeff kuhn's pile of
play-doh before you scoff please note
that this is a real art piece that was
purchased for over 22 million dollars
but every days doesn't exactly strike
you right away as being the kind of art
that advisors would stake their
reputation on so color us still
mystified that said there are some
consistent trends that tend to ascribe
particular value to certain pieces of
art also fun fact blue and red paintings
inexplicably tend to sell for more but
overall scale tends to be a huge
determinant in the value of art if you
want to sell something for millions of
dollars it better command a lot of wall
space obviously every day's composed of
5000 images is the digital equivalent to
taking up the entire wall of a museum
another big factor is novelty as we saw
with zombie formalism the novelty of an
art purchase can also intrinsically give
it value in this case the prospect of
being the first collector to buy an nft
from a major auction house no doubt
played a role in the month-long bidding
war that drove the price up to again and
i cannot stress this enough 69 million
dollars but there's also the matter of
self-interest one of the big reasons
that certain artists like andy warhol
have become worth so much is actually a
little bit sketchy art collectors who
already own a couple of warhols might
bid incredibly high on the next warhol
that comes up at an art auction it's
because doing so helps the warhol brand
in the eyes of the art world
consequently inflating the value of
their pre-existing soup can collection
of course their old war halls didn't
suddenly improve in quality curator and
dealer kenny schachter notes that this
phenomenon was especially prevalent
during the era of zombie formalism
saying there was definitely price
manipulation at the beginning with
investors bidding up the works at
auction to the hundreds of thousands of
dollars we suspect something similar
though way more expensive is going on
with the sale of every day's the two
buyers vignesh sun deraison aka
medicovan and anad venkatsuaran are
cryptocurrency entrepreneurs sunderersun
started metapurse aka a crypto exclusive
fund that specializes in identifying
early stage projects across blockchain
infrastructure finance art unique
collectibles and virtual estate that's a
fancy way of saying we invest in nice
digital
medicoven had already bought several
other art pieces by people months before
the recent auction he subsequently
divided ownership of this body of work
collectively called b20 and sold shares
of them publicly via b20 tokens but
here's where it gets kinda juicy he kept
59 of the tokens for himself while his
favorite business partner one mr beeple
owns two percent independent
cryptojournalist amy caster argues that
the purchase of every days thus
represented a consequential conflict of
interest she postulates that it was all
probably a mere publicity stunt to a
publicize metapurse and the whole b20
package and b increased the value of
that package i.e the rest of medecovin's
existing people collection thus making
v20s more valuable and a much more
exciting investment opportunity after
the sale of every days the value of a
b-20 coin shot up from just 36 cents in
january to 23
though it has since dropped to seven
dollars but still it's not small bananas
the two buyers have since issued a
statement claiming that this purchase
was intended to show indians and people
of color that they too could be patrons
that crypto was an equalizing power
between the west and the rest and that
the global south was rising so if it
increased their collections values that
apparently is just a happy side effect
anyway does all this mean that nfts are
the future a slew of finance blogs might
have you thinking so as well as
medikovan's recent declaration that the
work will one day be worth a billion but
of course when it comes to something as
fickle as the art market it's never wise
to put all your money on the latest fad
as we saw with many of the top zombie
formalists something that's the toast of
the art market one day can have an
undignified fall from grace the next
take one dealer who invested one hundred
thousand dollars into zombie work by
hugh scott douglas in 2014 planning to
flip it for even more found himself
selling it for just twenty thousand
dollars a mere two years later after
kind of hilariously trying and failing
to hawk it on ebay he lamented i feel
like we were a little bit drunk and
didn't think of the consequences then
the bottom fell out everyone got stuck
with their pants down
sounds like my first time
will the same be said of every days
maybe
but what do you guys think are nfts the
future of the art market or just the
latest bubble and one of the weirdest
luxury economies let us know in the
comments big thanks to our patrons for
all your support hit that subscribe
button like it's worth
69 million dollars and don't forget to
ring that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you